We'll focus on the Drawing library so
we can fulfill Audrey's business need.
We'll load the drawing library
in the libraries parameter.
After loading the library,
we'll need to tell the map that
we plan to draw all over it.
So we'll create a new object
called the drawingManager
in our initialize function.
This allows us to specify
multiple drawing modes and
the position of the controls on the map.
I'm copying this right from our
developer site linked in the notes.
At first, we aren't going to set the map
on the drawingManager, so essentially
we're initializing it, but we aren't
going to have it appear right away.
We're telling it that our
default drawing mode and
our only drawing mode
is going to be polygon.
Other drawing modes are rectangle,
circle, polyline, and marker.
These require slightly different
handling than a polygon.
But polygons are the hardest, so if you
can do this one, you can do anything.
Next, we'll create a button
to allow the user to
toggle the drawing tools on and off.
We'll call it toggle-drawing and
we'll prompt the user to use it.
We'll also add in some more CSS.
Next we'll add in an event listener so
that when this button is clicked,
the drawing tools are either hidden or
shown.
We'll create a toggleDrawing
function for that and
pass in the drawingManager that we
created in the initialize function.
With this function, we're essentially
saying that when the user clicks on
toggle-drawing, check the map
property on the drawingManager.
If it's map, set it to null or
hide the drawingManager.
Or set it to map or
show the drawingManager.
Okay cool, now we can create
geometric overlays on our map.
So this still begs the question,
how do I actually use this to
search within it for listings?
Back to the code.
The next order of business is to add an
event listener so that when a polygon is
drawn on the map, we capture those
points into a polygon and use them.
I'm going to create
a global polygon variable
which is changed every time
a user draws a new polygon.
Next, we'll add the event listener.
The goal of this event listener is
that when the polygon is complete,
we're going to iterate through our
markers array, show all of the markers
that are within the shape and hide all
of the markers that are outside of it.
The first thing we're going to do is
check on our polygon variable to see if
it already has a value.
If it does,
we're going to hide it off the map.
By doing this, we're limiting
the user to one polygon at a time.
We could certainly allow multiple,
to let them select different zones.
For a better user experience, we're
going to assume that the user's done
drawing when the polygon is completed
and switch the pointer back to normal,
so that they can click on
the markers after they see them.
Then we'll capture the overlay
which was drawn and
assign it to our polygon variable.
We want the polygon to be editable,
so we'll set this to true.
We could make it draggable as well.
And finally, we'll call our
searchWithinPolygon function,
which we'll create below.
We also want to make sure
that the search is redone if
the polygon is edited.
So we'll add more event listeners
on the polygon itself, checking for
changes and re-executing the search.
Let's create our
searchWithinPolygon function.
This function uses the polygon
that was drawn by the user and
the marker's position and
uses more geometry library
functionality to check to see if
the polygon contains the marker.
If it does, we'll set the map property
to map on each marker, which shows it.
And if it doesn't,
we'll set it to null, which hides it.
This is going to result in only
the markers that are within the polygon
showing on the map.
Finally we'll add a little bit more
into our toggleDrawing function.
When the user is done drawing and
turns off the drawing tools,
we'll assume that they don't want to
see their polygon anymore, so
we'll remove the overlay, but
we'll keep the markers that appeared.
So let's test this out.
I'm going to turn on the drawing tools
and draw a quick polygon, there we go.
If the user wants to limit
the search to one or
two city blocks,
we'll see the listings there.
If they then decide to redraw the shape,
the search will be re-executed.
If I then turn off the drawing tools,
the shape will disappear, but
my markers will remain.
Never fear Ajay, you can do it however
you want with the Google Maps APIs.
>> Thanks for that Emily.
I would feel better, but
I just realized that we keep using lat
longs, and none of our students would
know the coordinates of
the places they want to use.
Also, I'm hungry.
>> You're right.
We better teach them about
geocoding after the next quiz.
And here.
>> Thank you.